[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
stéphane troussel bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes
président socialiste du conseil
départemental de seine saint denis on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représente une
manne fiscale jalabert ou jean pascal du
groupe ebra les journaux régionaux de
l'est de la france
on commence bien sûr stéphane troussel
avec cette crise sanitaire on attend
toujours la décision à nice mais a
priori des mesures restrictives
devraient être annoncés ce qui ferait
qu'il y aurait des mesures
territorialisées pour la première fois
en métropole est ce que c'est une bonne
chose cette territorialisation des
mesures pour vous en tout cas c'est la
preuve à la fois que le gouvernement
entend les territoires les élus locaux
et aussi adapte la stratégie moi je
considère effectivement que il faut
s'adapter à la réalité aux situations
différentes
et puis nous connaissons mieux désormais
ce virus cette épidémie est donc la
possibilité d'avoir des stratégies
différenciées me paraît effectivement
adapté et donc si cette ce confinement
territorialisée permet de faire chuter
les contaminations et soulagé le milieu
hospitalier de ce secteur
ça me paraît nécessaire on vous dit ça y
est on entend les élus parce que
longtemps les élus se sont plaints de ne
pas être écoutés de ne pas avoir assez
de dialogue de ne pas être entendu là
vous dites ça a changé est ce que vous
aussi vont constater en tout cas jean jé
j'ai entendu les élus locaux des
alpes-maritimes réclamer des mesures
supplémentaires donc à l'évidence le
gouvernement semble vouloir les entendre
on verra bien dans les heurts
donc on constatait ce changement de pied
avec les élus de la part du gouvernement
avec les autorités locales avec le
préfet de seine-saint-denis
quand on nous donne la main quand on
nous laisse travailler ensemble nous
savons mettre en oeuvre un certain
nombre de mesures nous avons ouvert 17
centres de vaccination en
seine-saint-denis et c'est notre
coopération locale avec les communes le
département la préfecture qui a permis
l'ouverture de 7,17 sentent oui y'a
encore faut-il que le gouvernement
laisse à la fois les élus et notamment
les autorités préfectorales travailler
ensemble et décider adapter les mesures
dans chacun des territoires
alors même si en région parisienne on
n'est pas dans l'étau circulation de la
moselle où des alpes-maritimes le virus
est très présent est on prêt à des
mesures plus coercitives plus drastiques
dans la région on le sait la densité de
population est très forte mais vous
savez moi je je je dis depuis des
semaines depuis des mois que il faut
tout faire par le renforcement des
mesures sanitaires par les gestes
barrières par la vérification du port du
masque par une stratégie vaccinale plus
développée avec plus de vaccins plus
adapté à la réalité des territoires
il faut tout faire pour éviter un
confinement généralisée parce qu'on sait
bien les conséquences économiques
sociales jeu les mesures dans un
territoire comme celui de la seine saint
denis et donc il faut tout faire pour
éviter cela mais bien évidemment c'est
la pression sur nos soignants la
pression sur le milieu hospitalier qui
dira dans les jours dans les semaines
qui viennent si des mesures plus
drastiques encore sont nécessaires d
accès seulement le week-end comme cela
semble être le cas dans les injustes
serait favorable psi
les statistiques chiffres les
indicateurs ne sont pas posées dans une
zone socialement entre guillemets
fragile où en est on comment vous sentez
la population est ce que ça c'est
beaucoup fragilisé ce que
psychologiquement à sa table pouvez-vous
nous nous dit on a dans le département
présenté comme le plus pauvre de france
où on en est il ya à la fois les deux
situations c'est à dire une situation
très nombreuses personnes qui ont et je
pense aux jeunes en particulier qui ont
perdu nous avons perdu le les jobs qui
ont perdu toute ressource et en même
temps beaucoup de solidarité beaucoup
d'initiatives à lire grâce aux
initiatives des associations des
collectivités locales les communes le
département l'ensemble des acteurs
locaux qui sont très mobilisés pour
permettre aux départements à la
population de faire face de tenir mais
en même temps c'est particulièrement
difficile quand je vois le nombre
d'allocataires du rsa augmenté très
fortement en seine-saint-denis comme
nous l avenir et on va revenir sur ces
questions sociales justes pour finir sur
les questions sanitaires
début aujourd'hui des tests salivaires
dans les écoles et notamment dans les
collèges dans le département la charge
alors à paris les les écoliers sont
encore en vacances mais sur les tests
salivaires qui vont être mises en place
à partir de la semaine prochaine est ce
que vous savez comment ça va se passer à
ce que là les choses se passent bien ce
que vous êtes prêts au moment où je vous
parle non les temps l'éducation
nationale que les autorités sanitaires
locales ne nous ont pas encore associé
ni informés des modalités d'organisation
de ces tests salivaires dans les
établissements scolaires notamment dans
les collèges alors que le département
effectivement gère les collèges aux
côtés l'éducation nationale c'est
indispensable si cette campagne de
de dépistage doit se déployer que les
collectivités locales là encore soit
associé à cette stratégie
et vous pensez que ça sera prêt la
semaine prochaine mais le faudrait si
c'est la volonté de l'état de déployer
ces tests de manière forte oui sur la
question de la vaccination est ce que là
les choses se sont améliorées en alu qui
avaient des habitants de paris et des
départements alentour qui venaient se
faire vacciner en seine-saint-denis au
détriment des habitants de
seine-saint-denis qui n'ont pas toujours
accès à la vaccination est ce que vous
ne le confirmer écoutez c'est le
résultat d'abord de la pénurie de
vaccins et donc il faut plus de vaccins
ça c'est la première des choses et puis
et bien dans un département comme la
seine saint denis où il y à des
inégalités sociales de santé très forte
que nous constatons une nouvelle fois à
l'occasion de cette politique de
vaccination et bien il faut s'adapter
aux réalités du territoire
qu'est ce que cela veut dire eh bien oui
il ne faut pas que cette stratégie
vaccinale dans un département comme la
seine saint denis elle passe uniquement
par les plateformes numériques type
d'octo libre parce que il y à un certain
nombre de personnes âgées de plus de 75
ans plus vulnérables plus fragile plus
isolé marquée par la fracture numérique
elle aussi est donc et sodome ce type de
résultat est donc là encore il faut
s'adapter aux réalités du territoire ça
veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'il faut déployer une
stratégie vaccinale qui va vers les
populations
cette stratégie d'aller vers les
populations elles se déploient enfin
davantage depuis quelques jours avec
l'ouverture d'un centre de vaccination à
à bobigny de la caisse primaire
d'assurance maladie est là et bien les
rendez vous sont organisés à la suite
d'appels téléphoniques passés par les
agents de la caisse primaire d'assurance
maladie par les centres communaux
d'action sociale par le département pour
aller chercher les populations organiser
les rendez vous j'ai bon espoir que dès
la semaine prochaine
la rs
va déployer davantage de doses qui va
vous permettre par exemple aux
départements d'organiser c'est ce que
nous avons fait depuis une semaine un
bus de la vaccination
pour l'instant il fait de l'information
mais dès la semaine prochaine j'espère
bien qu'il y aura des vaccins à bord de
ce bus pour et bien vaccinés au bord du
comment vous pouvez faire pour que les
doses prévues pour la seine saint denis
soit bien réservé aux habitants de la
salle st gelais et bien notamment en
faisant en sorte que ces doses
elle n'est elle ne fasse pas tout
l'objet d'une de créneaux sur les
plateformes numériques mais qu'elles
soient réservées par ces politiques là
d'aller vers un gouvernement un autre
système qu'ils soient complémentaires et
c'est ce que nous faisons quand nous
organisons ces prises de rendez-vous
différemment des plateformes numériques
et on va justement parlé de la crise
sociale robert va commencer par les
jeunes puisque vous êtes aussi dans un
département où la population est très
jeune
faut-il rsa jeunes que refuse le
gouvernement
sachant que le rsa ça rentrait chercher
mais oui il le faut
moi je fais partie de ces départements
de gauche qui depuis maintenant près de
deux ans sont mobilisés pour qu'il y ait
un revenu de la za revenu de base ça
veut dire quoi qu'ils fassent que on
lutte contre le le non recours au droit
que qu'il soit inconditionnels
automatique et élargi aux jeunes de 18 à
25 ans il faut tout de même savoir que
la france est désormais un des rares
pays en europe qui n'a pas élargi ses
minima sociaux aux jeunes de moins de 25
ans 23 des 27 pays de l'union européenne
ont désormais un minima social pour les
jeunes de 18 à 25 ans il n'ya face à
sète
la violence de cette crise sociale c'est
incompréhensible inqualifiable
injustifiable face à ces files
d'attentes devant les soupes populaires
maintenant tous les soirs dans nos dans
nos villes à paris et dans l'ensemble du
pays
ces files d'attentes qui se multiplient
il faut une réponse d'urgence et que la
majorité parlementaire
la république en marche repousse ce
débat comme
elle l'a fait la semaine dernière avec
la proposition de boris vallot hervé
saulignac d'un rsa pour les jeunes c'est
incompréhensible et même de refuser que
cette expérimentation soit possible
pendant le temps de cette crise c'est
injustifiable mais vous avez entendu ce
que vous a répondu le gouvernement
durant ce débat que l'ambition de l'état
n'est pas que les jeunes soient
locataires et que la réponse de l'état
et de donner des perspectives est ce que
vous l'entendez cet argument mais quelle
perspective ils ont à leur offrir en ce
moment même alors que ces jeunes alors
que ces jeunes perdre le leur leur
emploi alors que le cdh les cdd sont ne
sont pas renouvelées que l'intérim est
drastiquement diminué qu'elles du
gouvernement il ya la garantie jeunes
qui a été la garantie que ces 200
millions abc c'est quand même des
solutions mais elles mais elles si je
les prends tout tout et je les
accompagnerai tout mais on voit bien que
ce n'est pas à la hauteur du défi qui
nous est posée parce que sinon il n'y
aurait pas ces files d'attentes tous les
soirs désormais à paris pour de la
distribution alimentaire et donc la
gravité de la crise et celle qui nous
attend vraisemblablement dans les mois
qui viennent nécessite une réponse
structurelle et comme encore une fois la
mène déjà depuis longtemps
la quasi totalité des pays de l'union
européenne sur les étudiants parce qu'il
ya aussi plus spécialement les étudiants
là aussi il ya eu des mesures prises par
le gouvernement les repas un euro
l'échec si le retour d'une partie des
cours en présentiel est ce que là vous
dites ce sont des bonnes solutions est
ce que vous avez constatez-vous une
amélioration cette année
mais encore une fois ce sont des mesures
nécessaires mais qui ne sont pas
suffisantes face à la halle à l'ampleur
à la violence à la dure et
vraisemblablement de la crise économique
et sociale dans un département où comme
le mien ou y compris la part des
étudiants qui doivent travailler pour
financer leurs études est encore plus
grande et qui en ce moment face par
exemple
à la baisse d'activité sur la plate
forme de roissy à la disparition des
petits jobs dans le secteur de la
restauration de l'hôtellerie
tous ces petits jobs qui permettait à
aux étudiants de non seulement de vivre
et de financer leurs études tous ces
petits jobs et bien ils sont à l'arrêt
aujourd'hui donc il faut des mesures et
des mesures aussi que le rsa alors pour
un des partants comme le vôtre un coût
considérable et pèse sur vos budgets
comment allez vous arrivez à financer
tout ça et aujourd'hui quel est le
niveau du rsa en seine saint denis
combien ça vous coûte et que vous
capable de faire plus avec plus de monde
oui vous le savez bien je suis aussi
engagée depuis de nombreuses années pour
que cette allocation individuelles de
solidarité
elle relève d'un financement de la
solidarité nationale c'est d'ailleurs
l'objet de notre mobilisation depuis
très longtemps
les départements ont été mises en grave
difficulté financière depuis le
transfert des trois allocations
individuelles de solidarité que sont le
rsa l'apa la fondation depuis 2004 et on
voit avec cette crise à quel point cette
situation va être particulièrement
douloureuse pour les finances du
département et donc moi j'ai engagé déjà
depuis maintenant de nombreux mois une
mobilisation pour que l'état accepte
notamment en seine-saint-denis mais je
souhaite que ce soit possible ailleurs
mais en tout cas le premier ministre m'a
fait savoir qu'il était favorable à
l'ouverture d'une négociation avec la
seine-saint-denis pour expérimenter à
partir du 1er janvier 2022
une un financement à nouveau national du
rsa pour la seine-saint-denis que cette
position n'est pas partagée par tous les
présidents de départements est ce que
élargir le rsa ce n'est pas à mettre vos
collègues dans la difficulté
ça va de pair avec un nouveau mode de
financement de du rsa bien évidemment
mais moi je me refuse à ce que c'est ce
débat sur l'élargissement du rsa et bien
ne
n'ait pas lieu alors même que la crise
sociale s'amplifie
la question du financement c'est un
débat que nous menons depuis longtemps
et le besoin d'une réponse structurelle
en urgence face à la crise qui nous
attend est absolument nécessaire
on va parler du reste de l'actualité
frédéric vidal notamment qui persiste et
signe dans le journal du dimanche sur
l'islamo gauchisme qui gangrène les
universités est-ce qu'elle n'a pas
raison de s'attaquer à ce phénomène
écoutez cette sortie est
incompréhensible d'abord la même
ministre
il ya quelques mois face au même débat
expliqué qu' il y avait la liberté
académique expliqué que c'était pas ça
le problème de fond qui était posée à
l'université a pas de remise en cause de
la liberté académique alors qu'elle
vient d'être recadré sévèrement par les
présidents d'université recadré
sévèrement par le scrs paraît-il recadré
par le président de la république en
conseil des ministres la semaine
dernière elle persiste elle signe
écoutez moi je ne crois pas au hasard en
politique c'est une au moment où il y a
quelques jours encore le ministre de
l'intérieur trouvait la chef de
l'extrême droite de qualifiait la chef
de l'extrême droite de mol lors d'une
émission télévisée
il ya quelques jours encore tout ça est
ce une stratégie délibérée et je pense
que la majorité parlementaire
la république en marche joue avec le feu
ces ministres font comme si il était à
la veille d'un second tour de l'élection
présidentielle où ils sont face à
l'extrême droite
nous n'en sommes pas là c'est dangereux
pour le pays c'est risqué pour le pays
les français ne veulent pas de ce duel
débat duo confisqué par la république en
marche et l'extrême droite et donc il
joue avec le feu la ministre vidal
ferait bien de se préoccuper de la
précarité des étudiants et de leur
détresse psychologique
si elle a des combats à mener je
l'attends seine-saint-denis il ya
soixante mille étudiants il n'y a pas en
seine-saint-denis de bureaux dead
psychologique universitaire il y en a
quatre à paris 3dans val de marne
si vraiment elle veut être utile en ce
moment qu'elle vienne créer un bureau
d'être psychologique universitaire dans
mon département
elle peut encore rester à son poste face
à un tel désaveu de 2,2 de la communauté
universitaire elle est surtout très
affaibli très affaibli et surtout très
absente sur la crise universitaire la
crise des étudiants de démissionner bah
écoutez ça ce n'est pas de ma
responsabilité dans la vème république
c'est surtout la responsabilité du
président de la république mais enfin
avoir des ministres faible ça n'a pas
l'air de déranger beaucoup de présidents
qui vous dérange précisément dans cette
demande d' enquête faite par frédéric
vidal mais elle dit elle même que
finalement ce n'est pas le sujet là de
l'université quilit-quilit et dès qu'il
y ait des débats et que c'est un
phénomène mineur et mes seins dit elle
disait il ya quelques mois que c'est un
phénomène minoritaire
et puis surtout ce terme ne signifie
rien ne veut rien dire
c'est un thème exclusivement delà de la
polémique politique qui leur manuel
valls élan la définition d'une
islamo-gauchiste midi c'est simple c'est
l'alliance directe ou indirecte entre
une partie de la gauche et des slams
politique oui mais enfin on connaît les
positions extrémistes de manuel valls
est le même qui en espagne manifeste
avec l'extrême droite contre le
gouvernement de pedro sanchez donc très
franchement ça fait longtemps que je
n'écoute plus les sorties de manuel
valls
on va parler d'un oui un sujet lyon la
mairie nos lions qui impose des menus
végétariens dans les com
keane pour des réseaux sanitaires auront
c est vous le savez vous êtes bien placé
que pour beaucoup d'enfants dans la
cantine c'est le seul moment pour manger
de la viande avoir des protéines
que pensez vous de cette décision et
surtout est-ce que ça n'ajoute pas au
malaise de nos agriculteurs
non mais franchement encore une fois une
polémique qui qui qui est vraiment créé
toutes pièces je vois des ministres mais
ils n'ont rien d'autre à faire que sa
tâche et s'attacher à débattre de ce
sujet en ce moment d'une municipalité
qui prend une mesure et les mêmes
ministres
est-ce qu'ils ont été muets il ya
quelques mois quand c'était leur ami
gérard collomb maire en marche
ancien ministre de l'intérieur des
manuellement macron qui mettait en
oeuvre la même
mesure la même mesure ils n'ont
strictement rien dis donc on est
typiquement dans le petit débat
politicien de polémiques partisanes le
ferait dans les collèges de vos
départements mais je l'aï à une
organisation locale qui dit et qui fait
que le mr comme son prédécesseur dit
c'est plus facile de nous organiser de
cette manière là donc on peut pas
réclamer vous me dire en permanence il
faut laisser les élus locaux
s'organisent et laisser la liberté des
territoires s'adapter aux réalités
locales
et puis quand il ya des élus locaux qui
prennent des mesures pour s'adapter à
leur fonctionnement à leurs difficultés
de fonctionnement lancé une polémique
ça rejoint exactement ce que je disais à
l'heure où on a l'impression de tout à
l'heure on a l'impression de ministres
qui sont utilise toutes les polémiques
sur des sujets qui ne sont pas le coeur
des débats de la société française
aujourd'hui les débats de la société
française c'est quelle réponse on
apporte au caisson santé à la crise
violente qui nous attend sur le plan
économique et social à la nécessité
rappelée par cette crise de localiser
relocaliser des indics des activités
industrielles d'avenir d'apporter des
réponses nouvelles en matière
d'alimentation durable et et voilà
qu'ils se jettent sur le moindre sujet
pour faire le buzz
franchement notre pays n'a pas besoin de
ça on va parler des régionales pour
terminer la gauche qui n'arrive pas à
s'unir en ile de france et avec
clémentine autain et audrey pulvar ya
juillet un bâillon pour les verts est ce
que vous n'êtes pas en train d'offrir un
boulevard à valérie pécresse
moi je suis pour le rassemblement tout
le temps partout à toutes les élections
moi justement je ne veux pas enfermer
mon pays et en particulier ma famille
politique mon camp politique celui de la
gauche sociale écologique dans un duel
du haut entre la république en marche et
l'extrême droite est donc partout je
souhaite le rassemblement donc oui je
souhaite que d'ici les élections du mois
de juin et bien il y ait une offre qui
rassemble le plus largement possible la
gauche sociale écologique
on verra bien en tout cas moi jusqu'au
bout je continue la porte et audrey
pulvar à faire dans ce sens un premier
chemin avec un premier rassemblement
avec les socialistes avec des citoyens
engagés
avec des écologistes avec le parti
radical de gauche avec place publique
avec d'autres formations politiques
c'est un premier pas je souhaite bien
évidemment qu'on aille le plus loin
possible dans ce rassemblement il faut
continuer pour offrir justement cette
alternative sociale écologique dont je
crois
le pays a besoin hier dans les colonnes
du journal du dimanche najat vallaud
belkacem a dit que la division est
suicidaire et que c'est la marque d'une
gauche qui s'est embourgeoisé à la
raison en tout cas je crois que nos
électeurs c'est ce qu'il nous demande
est d'ailleurs innocent quand elle quand
elle ne répond pas suffisamment aux
aspirations des catégories populaires
que ce soit dans les territoires urbains
comme ceux de la seine-saint-denis mais
aussi dans les territoires ruraux qui
souffrent bien oui elles ne répondent
pas à l'aspiration qui doit être celle
qui doit porter prioritairement c'est
moi je crois que pour l'emporter pour
qu'il y ait une gauche sociale
écologique qui soit de nouveaux crédits
pour le pays il faut cette nouvelle
alliance entre les catégories populaires
et un certain nombre de catégories
mélenchon mais en tout cas c'est les
électeurs qui se reconnaissent dans jean
luc mélenchon eh bien il au deuxième
tour ils prennent le bulletin du
candidat de gauche qui est le mieux au
département de la seine-saint-denis ma
majorité elle va des socialistes aux
écologistes en passant par les
communistes la france insoumise des
citoyens et citoyennes engagées et nous
portons un bilan une action ensemble
pour l'égalité pour la justice pour la
transformation écologique de la scène
samedi et merci beaucoup merci à vous
fans trop salades venues nous voir parce
qu'elle regarde la une du progrès
consacré à cette décision c'est donc
cette décision avec grégory douce et qui
bien entendu s'exprime
et puis face à lui nous avons interrogé
un éleveur de vaches charolaises qui est
d'ailleurs le propriétaire de la vache
iconique du salon de l'agriculture
et qui dit évidemment tout le mal qu'ils
pensent cette décision et c'est très
intéressant parce qu'il dit qu'elle va à
l'encontre l'environnement vu que pour
remplacer la viande qui ne sera pas
livré avant d'importer du soja
d'amérique du sud
et voilà ces salaires dans le
merci mon dieu merci c'est pas trop ça
des justement on va continuer à parler
d'agriculture tout de suite dans le club
des territoires la mutuelle nationale
territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux vous présente le club des
territoires angie acteurs engagés dans
la transition zéro carbone des régions
vous présente le club des territoires
[Musique]